this how i get into stuff so i'd say
once or twice a year i revisit
uh the charles manson [ __ ] i love the
charles manson stuff
so i was this is podcast he kept talking
about spawn ranch and i never knew i
don't know why i never looked it up i
never knew where it was at and so
uh the podcast i was looking uh
listening to on my bike ride
they said spawn ranch and then they set
a area chatsworth and i'm like
chatsworth i'm like what's that why have
i heard of that and i'm like i know
where the [ __ ] that's at
it's not too far from my house so so
then on my bike i was on there
i looked up spawn ranch i'm like oh [ __ ]
it's only like 11 miles from me
so i bike i'd rode my bike to spawn
ranch son
so spawn ranch is where charles banson
and the
family like all the girls they lived
there for two years
so that's where supposedly we can get
into that supposedly that's where he
came up with the plan to
uh helter skelter kill sharon tate
uh that's where he'd write his songs his
music and all that that's where all the
girls were that's where like
the music producer would visit the ranch
and and
see him play his tunes and [ __ ] so you
go there it's a little
airy but it the the manson he only
rolled with
he only just had a bunch of girls no he
wanted more guys she wanted like muscle
but a lot of guys like
didn't really [ __ ] with them like they
thought he was weird the only reason
anyone kind of chilled with him because
those girls he would like
they could have whatever they want with
the girls yeah so like terry
melcher and like the like the the beach
boy guy who was really into him
who kind of helped him out yeah and they
would chill at the beach boys house
um in the hills he would only [ __ ] with
him because he had all these hot girls
yeah and he could [ __ ] all the girls
and then they but he didn't really do
anything who or the
beach guy the beach guy the beach guy he
[ __ ] the girls but that's it
that's it and it wasn't like he then he
thought charles manson had talent
yeah and then charles manson wrote a
song and then he
took the that song and put it on the
beach boys album
and gave charles manson no credit oh and
so
charles manson so he was actually a good
musician he was good he was just like on
discipline so like when they put him in
a studio so that beach boy guy and terry
melcher hooked him up and put him in
studios to get him passed by like sony
and universal
but he'd get to the like the with the
where they like
audition them is what you say you get to
the sound stage
and then he'd fight with the like
control guy
because the guy like hey try this or try
this and he like pulled a knife on one
of the guys
it's wild yeah he's just like an outlaw
so like people like we can't have that
we can't deal with this dude yeah
and he didn't have the talent like
undeniable yeah like if drake's not
[ __ ] pulls the knife i was like
all right we'll figure it out
all right yeah man you're like get the
[ __ ] out of here because he wasn't
really anything
no but at the time he was you know he's
like this is he from here
i think no he's not from here yeah he's
not from here but what's
what's weird about charles mance is like
you know with like the fake news and
like to put
the corona fair and everybody yeah the
russia fake news and
like the media now is like right they
just on they
they they get views and hits off fair
like selling people fair that's
that's what they do like cnn [ __ ] but
this was real
a little bit but like even back then
like they were doing the same [ __ ] with
charles mentioned like
like the tom o'neil who wrote chaos and
he gets into it about the cia and
charles manson working with the cia yeah
doing all this [ __ ] in uh haight ashbury
in san francisco
like the whole helter skelter thing and
like yeah
the whole like he who's this mastermind
all this like that was a narrative that
the media created
like charles manson's like what the [ __ ]
like i didn't even like the beatles they
did i heard that they could catch eyes
on them like sometimes well they did it
because it was like
think of the narrative like it's the
most infamous yeah
they call him a serial killer to make
sense so he's the most infamous serial
killer of our time
and like that whole narrative was kind
of it was out of the helter skelter book
that they that the belusi wrote like
that whole narrative the prosecution
kind of made up to pitch to the courts
yeah and then the news got a hold of it
and they're you know yeah and they said
he was going to try killing steve
mcqueen and
ellen john like all these super famous
people so
i i can't remember if you told me this
or someone told me did they like
give him like lsd yeah they they asked
and elsie and hate ashby and like oh in
prison and he would go to those in so
the
the feds or feds or d.a would have
houses where they'd give like john's as
they call them they
get them in with girls that was in the
hills yeah no no that wasn't
a hater in san francisco oh god i got it
so they give you give them all this lsd
and then and
acid and all this [ __ ] then you know in
that chaos book you talk about like
they would they knew where charles
manson was at and they would like the
cops like oh we're gonna go get him like
he's on
don't touch him right now yeah and like
he got away so many times
like his parole officer never [ __ ]
like they would let him like travel when
he
shouldn't like it's super suspect so
they you think they set him up
no i think he's crazy i think he's oh
you do he's an evil dude i just don't
buy the narrative
but he also like he like yeah he told
like maybe the narrative is he told
those people to kill
everybody but then it's like he's not a
killer
you know what i'm saying like the real
killer's text watson who's his muscle
yeah and tex watson his he did an
interview and those tapes has never been
released
ever because he didn't go to the
narrative that held her skelter
so you know what helter skelter's from
helter skills yeah helter skelter's a
song from the beatles
helter skelter is a famous roller
coaster in england
so it's not like this evil it sounds
evil as [ __ ]
helter scout because because we
associate with charles manson yeah
beatles like [ __ ] that's a roller
coaster
[Laughter]
you know what i'm saying it's like six
flags yeah you know yeah it's just like
yeah that ride it's a ride
if we call it magic mountain or splash
mountain yeah
it's weird dude you look into it it's
interesting
but then and then like yeah see where i
ride is to die for
and the reason one of the reasons got
caught is because that uh i think your
name is susan
atkins she was she got picked up for
something else and she was in prison she
started bragging
about the murders and then one of the uh
her cellmates
was like i gotta tell someone about this
and then so
and then when they killed sharon tate
like it was just how'd they kill her
dude so it was just [ __ ] up huh dude
you want me to talk about it
i mean yeah let's get into it so
somebody didn't even let me know he
looked at me
so sharon sharon tate who was pretty
famous right
pretty famous super gorgeous sharon tate
and then uh the folger uh daughter who
you know the the
coffee the coffee yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're not billionaire i've seen her
yeah and then there was like two other
people in the house one one was a guy so
two girls two guys and sharon tate yes
now that old house should be terry
melcher's house he owns it
but he rented it out to them to polanski
who was sharon tate's husband roman
roman
but terry melcher was the owner and also
terry melcher was the guy
who could give charles manson's record
contract so charles manson and texas
watson went to that house
year before way before having parties he
they'd go
for parties and he was the guy who was
the key to his success like he thought
he was gonna be the beatles
he thought he's gonna be like charles
manson he thought he's gonna be like jim
morrison his whole family thought he's
gonna be like jim morrison
oh so they thought so when they just
were like [ __ ] it you're not getting a
record deal nothing like that
that's when he was like [ __ ] these
people these rich people are taking from
us we're gonna kill the rich
so he went to the house not knowing
sharon tate or folger was in there they
just knew
that somebody rich was in there it
wasn't like a headline oh it wasn't
like oh we're going to get there like
they went to the house previously to
talk to terry melcher
and they're like terry melcher don't
live here this is roman polanski's house
like oh and then sharon tate walked out
and he saw her she's like damn she's hot
and then left didn't think anything of
it and then when he came up with the
plan to kill everybody
he sent them there tex watson and the
three girls sent them there was like
just kill the rich people and make it
look real gory
so sharon tate was pregnant as [ __ ] they
killed her
they stabbed the baby they they stabbed
her a [ __ ] ton
uh the dude they they stabbed like a
gillian [ __ ] times
like you're talking about how much is
that like
a ton like tex watson did almost all the
killing
ah gnarly [ __ ] dude and she just
happened to be there
they're just there get killer rich yeah
kill the rich and then
then he was mad at the record labels
yeah because he thought it was like
they're
going through the record it was like
well he wanted to because he thought
roman polanski lived there
and that's a house they got out for sale
now well this [ __ ] is wild
it's wild [ __ ] was different back then
it's kind of complex but
but then but then when you watch all of
charles manson's like interviews which
i've watched a ton of them
he's never admitted like he's like i
didn't kill those people he's like this
whole like
hippie thing and family he's like i
don't know what the [ __ ] people are
talking about
and then he goes you know i tried
shaving before this interview but they
wanted me to look crazy
so i have to leave my hair long and to
have this [ __ ] so i look crazy
what explains the swastika on his head
he had to in
in prison he had to side with the alien
nation so they would protect them
because everyone wanted to [ __ ] want
to kill him so he had to say oh so he's
like oh i'll link up with aaron nation
so that's when he did all that [ __ ] yeah
and they
talked about that they protected him
that makes sense because he wanted
muscle so he there was i think they're
called the straight satan was a
motorcycle gang
and they he they used to hang out at the
ranch [ __ ] all the girls
and he tried like getting them to jump
on board with them and they were like
the [ __ ] out of here like no one took
him seriously
no one took him seriously and he was
just trying to make music yes this guy
was just trying awesome
you know what else is surprising about
charles manson you know he's 5'4
he's a little dude tiny dude
was he beating he so he didn't beat him
he didn't touch anybody
well he might have shot a guy but no he
like you he
like he would get in a fight but he
didn't do any of those murders
now he did tie up the family in los
feliz yeah he went and tied that did he
kill him
nope he left he just left oh they were
just tied up there and and then they're
good and then the sharon
no they murdered him and then the sharon
tate family
once tex came back to the ranch i was
like yo we killed him he's five two
five two bro wikipedia five two so he's
probably yeah he's from
he's from cincinnati that's where white
mike is from white mike
nope see victims nine
but the the family says uh they killed
35. what does that mean
uh killed by a proxy he didn't do it
himself he had someone else do it
oh god it like so if you would be like
man it'd be like saying a mafia boss is
a serial killer
because he orders the killings you never
call him mafia guy
uh you never call uh uh uh like you know
gambino or like any of these high level
gotti of serial killer but they've
killed way more people the narrative's
weird to me shout out to boardwalk
it's all it's all super weird yeah but
but but when when he did that like la
was freaking the [ __ ] out so all the
famous people had private security
you couldn't buy any german shepherds
guns went out of stock
because everyone thought like this
killer was on the loose it took them
forever to catch them by the way
oh to catch yeah and this is what else
is weird
and so they so they they this story is
what's nuts so they kill a guy in
tapanga he was a
a music instructor they killed him they
killed the shantae family
then the next day they killed the family
in los feliz
the stupid [ __ ] cops didn't put any
of it together they were working
individual cases they didn't they didn't
think it was it was
associated with each it was it was they
never put it together until after
so it took forever so
i have two questions
so when the the triangle like you said
it took them a minute to
put it together and it was because
they're talking about different pieces
so yeah you're talking about los feliz
yeah talking about l.a
lapd and into penguins which is
different jurisdictions
yeah but don't the police like reach out
to these
jurisdictions not back then no no no
they had like it was like yeah now they
do
because like even like the golden state
killer so he would kill all up and down
the coast yeah he'd kill in one
jurisdiction
kill here they never put it together so
back then they'd have to call mckay have
you seen that's how those [ __ ]
get away
yeah not now now it's all over like i
don't think they don't catch jeffrey
dahmer
a hot second really hot second
so back then killing was like easy to
get away with way easier think about no
cameras
no there's now there's a street camera
everywhere everywhere
everywhere people don't even know
nothing but that's so
what charles manson would do is he would
get these girls who had like broken
families like
lost and he'd be just like kill him with
kindness and then
give him all these drugs like lsd and if
you're a part of the
family you couldn't there's no alcohol
he didn't believe in drinking you could
do a bunch of like lsd and acid and [ __ ]
and marijuana but no no drinking
and so then he was supposed to turn up
lsd but then they huge him real high and
then
like spit all the [ __ ] at him all this
knowledge so they thought he was like
a second coming of [ __ ] jesus christ
oh so this is like he had him in a cult
oh dude it was a cold and they called
himself a family yeah
someone else gave him that name the
family they did an article i'm in
rolling stones
they gave him the name of family he
never referred himself as a culver
family
it's super interesting it's kind of
what's weird to me is that text what
this is where it all it all relies on
text watson's
his text text text he's from texas
oh god texts they call him text watson
he was doing he was the muscle he's one
who did all the murdering he was a
[ __ ]
brutal how big was he can you look at
that huge
but it all what if you want to know what
what happens
those tapes have they've never released
them those are the
those tapes will tell us what's going on
is he still alive
i don't know he's in prison for like
662.
not that big not small though especially
think about the people back then he's
still in jail are you still in jail
according to i'm he's in san diego
you're going to go down i'm going to
drive down what you're going to say hey
what's your side of the story
does he i would love to hear because he
because they say they won't release his
because his
narrative on what like the the killings
isn't the helter skelter like he's like
what no we weren't killing [ __ ]
that's not why we did it
and we like we weren't trying to start a
race war like you know that stuff
but then that's what they delay like you
said the media the helper skelter book
which is one of the best-selling books
of all time it was that
that painted that narrative exactly
skeleton
he got a lot of eyes like you said the
title was a [ __ ] ton
what did you say more recent 2014 this
is him
that's him in 2014. it feels like he
still looks young yeah he looks like he
got his life together i know right what
the [ __ ]
you teach kids in prison yeah i like
that
but people didn't want to kill him he
didn't get linked up with the aryan
nation
no one [ __ ] uh you you because
smiling
he's the one that did all the killing
all the killing this guy he's the bad
guy no one talks about him
maybe he just want his credit that's why
he's just but charles manson like
like if you watch a geraldo revere did
an interview with him
and he's like people think you're a
killer stuff like he's like what the
[ __ ] you talking about
he's like the family's like he's not a
cult and then he's like well you seem
crazy he's like
wouldn't you be pissed if you've been
locked up for 18 years and people keep
paying this narrative like you're this
[ __ ] monster
all the time yeah he's like you guys are
scared of me
he's like me and then he goes into
prison he was kind of the first one he's
like that's fake news man he's like this
narrative you guys are painting isn't
real
got it and then he goes into prison and
they want to kick his ass so he gets
with aaron
nation and then he had such control over
the girls when he was on trial
he shaved his head they all shaved their
head he put an x here
they put an x there crazy [ __ ] dude
but that susan atkins a piece of [ __ ]
she she did a you know
she wanted that stabbed shin tate in the
stomach had no
remorse for you well she looks crazy
she's a real piece of [ __ ] too she got a
pimple on her lip what is that it's got
a blister on her lips it looks like a
cold sore
on her head too yeah a lot of them had
stds because the whole family like
someone get it they would all get it
because you used to sleep with everybody
she so she's the one that killed sharon
tate
she says there's tex watson later down
you know laters
after but years later but
yeah it's interesting right yeah well in
lighter news yeah
lighter dudes is interesting because you
can go down there see where they're all
chilling like some of their rusted out
like shits on the ground
with like where they were hiding out in
there is there still where they took
shits
i'm sure they [ __ ] somewhere i don't
know that's what you were saying like
russ
we need rusted [ __ ]
so that susan atkins person died in 2009
right there what she did
well this whole this whole thing seems
exhausting
oh it's super interesting though
especially read that chaos book where it
goes into like
no i'm just talking about all that they
did this seems so exhausting
but but don't too lazy you don't you
know what's weird to think about like
what what would have happened if they
would have gave charles manson a record
contract
none of this would have happened if they
show it here dude yeah play your music
there's no murder well he also could
have went independent
what the [ __ ] did he not jump on that
back then there was no two
there was no independent but now he
jumped on soundcloud you know what i'm
saying
what year was it 69 69
uh august 669 damn if someone if [ __ ]
if there's a sound cloud that's what i'm
saying he was just like
right you go
if like the beach boys guy [ __ ] with
him this terrible [ __ ] with him like
he must be doing something
how about that when i get off stage at
the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this wrote a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son